Speaker 1: All right. This is this is
really weird. Many of you have asked me
to react to this podcaster, Joe Rogan, on
whose program I've appeared two times now,
seems to essentially be endorsing the dangerous,
radical, unhinged Republican governor of Florida,
Ron DeSantis. Now we're going
to look at what Joe Rogan said,
but one of the important things to keep in mind is
it's not just about, oh, Rogan likes the Santos.
There's another aspect to this, which is Rogan has
been insisting that he's like a progressive guy,
that his policy ideas are most in line
with someone like a Bernie Sanders.
So when you see someone who says, I really
am like a Bernie guy in a lot of ways,
when you see them say, I like DeSantis, you
have to ask questions like, Is it not true
that his policies most aligned with Bernie because
Bernie and DeSantis are basically polar opposites?
Or does he not even really understand what
these people's policies are? And he's going
on personality? I don't know the answer to any
of these questions, but let's take a look at the
video clip. Here is Rogan saying, DeSantis.
Speaker 4: DeSantis, didn't it Elon
Musk come out recently for DeSantis?
Speaker 5: Yeah, I think Ron DeSantis
would work as a good president, I think. I mean,
what he's done for Florida has been admirable.
Speaker 4: I'm doing breaking news right
now that wasn't even on purpose to do that.
Speaker 5: I feel like what he did for Florida,
a lot of people gave him a lot of grief. But
ultimately, he was correct. He was correct. So
it comes to like deaths. He was correct when it
comes to protecting our vulnerable populations. He
was correct in terms of distribution of monoclonal
antibodies. And he was furious when the government
tried to pull those, they were trying to pull
very effective treatments. You know, he is.
Speaker 1: Now just as a quick fact check,
the government wasn't trying to pull it. What
the government started to realize was that its
effectiveness was diminishing. And it may not
be the best course of action in some cases,
but it's it's it really has nothing to do
with the bigger picture here. Let's listen.
Speaker 5: Not perfect. He's a human being, but
what he's done is stand up for freedoms. And
people think that. So there's this was some weird
gaslighting shit that went on where people equated
freedom and saying the word freedom to like
right wing bigotry and hate is so strange.
Speaker 1: Well, sometimes that is exactly what
they meant by it. So there's two parts. Okay.
How did DeSantis do as Florida governor? And
then what about the prospect of Ron DeSantis
as president of the United States? So Florida,
despite being one of the top tourism states in
the country, no thanks to DeSantis. It's
not because of DeSantis that people go
to the Gulf Coast of Florida, to the beaches, to
the Atlantic coast of Florida, to the beaches, to
the various theme parks and resorts in Orlando, to
Miami Beach. That has nothing to do with the sand
is Florida has some great tourism attractions. And
despite that, Florida ranks 33rd in opportunity,
26th in crime, 41st in access to health care.
20% of Floridians have no health insurance.
And importantly, that's all been pretty similar
with the Santos governor. So DeSantis has handed
this tourism rich state and he doesn't improve any
of those disastrous numbers. Now, in terms of the
political positions of Ron DeSantis, first of all,
Ron DeSantis is against legalizing recreational
marijuana. Isn't this like a nonstarter for
Rogan? Rogan correctly supports legalization. I
agree with Rogan on that completely. The DeSantis
view on that issue is so antiquated, wouldn't it
be a disqualifying position for someone like
Joe Rogan evaluating a candidate? Does Rogan
know about that? Maybe he does. Maybe he doesn't.
DeSantis is just straight up against abortion. He
just he's just against abortion. Period. That's
it. Another retrograde, antiquated worldview.
Rogan has daughters. Wouldn't he want in certain
situations that to be an option, at least if his
daughters ever needed to avail themselves of such
a medical treatment? Is it just that none of it's
making any sense? And then, of course, you just
go deeper. And DeSantis is wrong on, you know,
all but like a few issues that he comes across.
The Santos was against the Iran nuclear deal.
He said it was a bad deal that would
degrade national security. In fact,
the deal worked really well until Donald Trump
stepped up and just said, we're out of the deal
even though Iran didn't violate the deal. I
mean, just terrible what Donald Trump did.
The deal was working fine. It wasn't. No
deal is perfect, but it was working well.
DeSantis is opposed to all gun safety regulations.
The NRA has rated DeSantis as an A-plus. Now,
maybe Rogan likes that. For me, it's completely
despicable. DeSantis called for a full and
complete repeal of Obamacare with, of course,
like all of these Republicans, no real substantive
and plausible plan for how to get people health
care. And as I mentioned, 20% of Floridians have
no health insurance. One out of five Floridians
does not have health insurance. DeSantis was
opposed to Deferred Action for Childhood
Arrivals. That's known as Dacca Dacca refers
to. You're seven years old. Your parents come to
the United States illegally. It's not your fault
you're seven. You go where your parents take
you. You then go to school. And then you go to
high school and ba ba ba ba ba. And what we should
be doing is saying, this is really your country.
You should be allowed to stay. We're going to
defer action because you were a childhood arrival.
Even many Republicans are okay with that. DeSantis
is against it. And DeSantis has a zero rating
from the Human Rights Campaign for his voting
record on LGBT related issues and legislation.
Everything I know about Rogan is that Rogan
is not homophobic and that Rogan believes
that everybody should be treated with dignity and
respect. And as for gay marriage and on and on,
and DeSantis has a zero rating. So when
it comes to Rogan on something like this,
does Rogan not know about the political
positions? Does Rogan just go on
personality? Does Rogan just go on rhetoric?
I don't know the answer, but it is bizarre
for someone who says I'm like most aligned with
someone like Bernie to say DeSantis would be a
good president. It's weird, and I don't know
what the explanation is, and I don't know how
much Rogan knows about what Ron DeSantis does
and stands for. But that's where we are right
now. And of course, Rogan has got a huge audience.
There are people who will hear this and go, Yeah,
I guess DeSantis. I don't know. DeSantis is good.
As I've said before, DeSantis is like a Trump,
but he's less incompetent and that makes
him much more dangerous. Scary stuff.